Uh,
what I'd like to do this morning is spend
eight or 10 minutes with a few slides
that are framing and background
of the case. And then,
um, I'm going to ask Nancy
Height to impersonate,
impersonate, share an Oscar with
the flying chalk on the board.
And I'm going to come around and talk
to all of you about the case and we'll
work it through B school style.
When you look at the institutions
involved in the mortgage system,
I don't assume that they
were designed brilliantly
or that they were thought
out from beginning to end.
The concept of Kluge is that
in your vocabulary, it's Tim,
is that Kluge?
Is that our curt hands up in [inaudible]
not going to get anywhere with that idea.
A kluge means things that are
complex and badly designed.
And there's a wonderful book by a
guy named Gary Marcus called Kluge,
which is about badly designed stuff,
uh,
from,
economic institutions to human memory,
to,
uh,
the human spine,
which is a highly error prone structure.
And it is as it is,
not because evolution said what's the
very best support call I can make for a
pipette bipedal creature.
But what's the best I can do by evolving
from a four if I get to a to like a
great trip.
And the spine shows all kinds of design
imperfections that are attributable to
the fact that it evolved in a horizontal
plane and then was readapted in a
vertical point and the
institutions at play
in what Posner calls the Depression of
Oh eight and what most of us called the
recession. Oh boy. Oh nine.
So it is perhaps the
mother of all recessions.
It has not actually attain
thought depth of unemployment
and under utilization of a plant and
equipment that would match up with the one
in the 1930 [inaudible] of course
we could still get there. Uh,
it is possible.
That is now 1931
and another dip is out there.
I don't think that,
but there are I including wheel gach
when we saw a few days ago who speculate
that it might be.
So.
Okay.
Uh,
this is a cast of characters
for subprime lending,
a left to right, uh, the
home buyer, the broker, the
appraiser, that mortgage lender,
the air,
the investment banker and the investors
in the bonds created by the investment
banks. And in the, the, uh,
the row I'm touching are the principal
incentives that make the whole system go.
And
the critical thing is that three and
arguably four of the main steps in the
process are fee driven.
So that the alignment between
the decision maker and the master
or between the decision maker
and the potential home buyer,
uh,
may be muted by the decision
maker thinking fees.
If I'm saying it,
let's suppose,
let's suppose I were a
college admissions officer
and I was paid by the wives
students still ever to the school,
I might become very generous in my views.
I might find creativity
in unexpected places.
I might imagine analytic fire
power where none existed.
And so in all these steps,
the bias toward yes,
the bias toward completing a transaction
a is a very powerful,
powerful piece of the story.
The risks are chartered here.
Uh,
what we're going to do well when
we do the case, among other things,
just to fill in the bottom bro,
what are the ways in which we would
expect people in each of these roles roles
to be tempted to get out of
line, out of line, ethically,
uh,
and quite possibly out of why legally
as in the case there is a broker,
right,
who gets way beyond both
ethical and legal bounds.
Home ownership in the United States,
1900 to 2000,
uh, looks like this. And
notice it's a truncated scale.
The bottom of the steel is 40%.
Uh,
the big story is a huge normative
emphasis on home ownership.
Uh, the belief, uh,
going back to Jefferson really,
that when people own
property, they become, uh,
bought in citizens,
citizens who identify with
the Commonwealth and who
can be counted on to act in
public spirited ways.
And
there's a great run up in home
ownership between World War Two, uh,
and the 1980s.
And it is fueled by a very profitable
mass development of suburban housing.
It is financed by,
uh,
uh, Fha and related,
uh, government entities.
And it is rewarded by the
internal revenue service tax code,
which gives a strong incentive for people
to take out mortgages on a principle
residence. Now, homeownership,
I assume, if any, do
any of you own a home?
Okay.
Oh, I should say that. Jaan [inaudible]
who wrote the cases with us,
welcome. Yawn. You own a house.
Sometimes I envy that
homeownership has all kinds of hazards,
right?
I just learned that my slate roof,
a hundred year old slate roof is at
the end of its lifetime and that's,
that's comparable to buy a,
it's about the same
price as the highest end.
BMW replace a slate roof.
That's a hazard.
Uh, suppose, uh, that uh,
you get laid off now your
mortgage payments continue.
Suppose that there is
a catastrophic illness.
The mortgage payments continue
the local property taxes continue.
The unanticipated
maintenance issues continued
and there is quite a lot to be said for
relative caution about undertaking a
debt amounting to several years
income in purchasing a house.
Now there's also a
political dimension to this,
which is that the old fashioned local
banking method of writing mortgages was
extremely cautious and was
first explosively and then
later implicitly racist
and gender rest.
It was all about well
employed white men and the,
that there is an any illogical
strand that is not Jeffersonian,
but it's more recent that has to do
with the equality of opportunity to own
houses,
which has pushed a policy toward
a more permissive attitude.
Uh, finally there is of
course the pro market view,
which became dominant in this
country in the Ronald Reagan era, uh,
which says let people cut the deals.
They want to cut,
get the government out of the transaction,
deregulate.
And in many cases, deregulation was
a spectacular success. For example,
the airline industry, uh,
the trucking industry, uh,
but deregulation of finance
is a slipper you're on,
you're taking
a history of home values here.
Uh,
what's emphasis an index chart
that has 1890 index to a hundred.
And the gist of the
argument in this chart,
did I take this from the
case or not? Uh, the,
the gist of the argument in this chart
is that by the time we're done with the
current meltdown,
a home values adjusted for inflation will
be back about where they were in 1890.
MMM.
This a map of Philadelphia and
it's historically interesting map.
I couldn't find a comparable one for
Cleveland though I'm sure. What exists.
In 1937,
uh,
mortgages were collapsing all over the
country and the Roosevelt administration
pushed through Congress a piece of
legislation called the home owners' Loan
Corporation, h o l LLC, home
owners' Loan Corporation.
And the home owners' Loan Corporation
was charged with finding out how to know
in advance if a mortgage
would likely fail.
And the technique was not
to look at credit scores,
but to look at housing locations and to
look at the condition of housing in a
neighborhood and at the
demographics of who lived there.
And it was crudely racist and uh,
uh,
biased in many, many ways. Uh,
it was explicitly racist about blacks.
It was explicitly racist about Jews.
It was explicitly racist about Italians,
most of all southern Italians.
And it was a four point scale.
The worst category.
Level D was Red and the term
redlining comes from this.
And the idea was to tell the banking
world not to lend money in those zones.
Uh, yellow was a little
better, uh, uh, then, then, uh,
blue,
then green.
And the idea was to put mortgage money
into the safest wealthiest neighborhoods
with the most homogeneous populations.
And from the point of view, uh,
managing the mortgage crisis,
it was not a terrible policy from the
point of view of managing cities and
communities.
It was catastrophic because what it
did was to accelerate the creation of
slumped in areas where mortgage money
was unavailable for the sale or purchase
of housing or for that matter,
for the large scale repair of housing.
Uh,
they did it to a 200.
They did the process to 200
American cities in a single year,
including new haven across
chapel street is class date.
Um,
this is the case shore home
prices story and what's
laid out here from the
year 2000, uh, to uh,
uh,
2000 Shabba.
And
this is when Gatesman talked about case
Schiller being a reassuring data series.
You look at it between here and here,
if you look at a, uh, a five year
period or even a six year period,
it looks like a process of continued
appreciation in home prices.
And there was nothing in the data that
would have given conventional econometric
models, would have triggered the
suspicion that the end was nigh.
Uh,
the chart is also interesting
because Cleveland is this line.
Yeah. So that Cleveland is, uh,
a less extreme story in
price appreciation then,
but the cases everybody
talks about, which, uh,
were, uh, Miami and Las
Vegas and Los Angeles,
uh, this is the same story shown
in year on year percentage change.
And,
uh,
it actually doesn't add much to our
knowledge. Hasn't got it. Skip it.
Yeah.
Uh, this is Cleveland, uh, uh,
uh, price appreciation, uh,
from 2000 into 2007 compared
with the country at large.
And the gist is that Cleveland was,
uh, not a hot, not a hot city.
And it was, it is in
that respect. I've got,
I've missed a charter.
There's a huge story about
northeastern industrial cities. Uh,
they, uh, by which I mean, uh,
virtually all the cities from Saint
Louis on the left side to Boston on the
right side,
uh,
they all had their takeoff in
the middle of the 19th century.
They were all going almost
vertical, uh, in the years,
1850 to 1900,
1910,
uh,
by 1920,
they're growth rates slowed
down almost to almost to zero.
Uh, and we're, uh,
fluctuated wildly during the depression
years recovered briefly in World War II
and then which sharply south
from 1950 on a new haven's case,
the strength of the inner city economy
forums and almost perfect arc with the
starting point in 1840,
the peak in 1950 and the bottom in about
1990 and there's actually been a little
bit of recovery since,
but Cleveland is a
classic industrial city.
It is the place where standard oil set
up its first large refining plants.
It was an at vantage point
in transportation because
it was an intersection
between very high quality east,
west freight rail and
Great Lakes shipping.
And it when rail became
subordinated to trucking,
uh,
and when suburban development
became dominant over the
reuse of industrial urban
neighborhoods,
Cleveland suffered mightily.
This income map of Cleveland where median
incomes under 22,700 are shown in the
darkest a rust tone,
uh,
is where the case takes place.
The green.is approximately the
location of Slavic village.
I wouldn't swear to it or argue with
yon if he said move it three or four
degrees of the compass north or east or
south or, but it's right about there.
And it is on the edge of a large
post industrial working class,
uh,
neighborhood or more mega neighborhood
in a declining industrial city.
Well,
there's the great art
and the concentration of
subprime lending in Cleveland,
shown in the darkest tones here,
includes the neighborhood
we're talking about.
And then there's Posner
on page two 84.
I hope all of you have
memorized page two 84.
It's worries apportioning blame,
but all,
although the financiers grabbed the
primary responsibility for the depression,
that's his name for the recession.
I do not think they can be blamed.
I tell it a blame for it.
Implying moral center.
Any more than one can blame
a lion for eating a zebra.
Capitalism is Darwinism.
Pretty dark interpretation.
Uh, and Nancy, can we,
how do we go? Here we go. Room controls
were from you. You'd Mod. Okay.
That's good to screen to go away.
Yeah.
Jennifer.
Yes.
So travel with letting me learn your name.
You get cold called.
Um, there's a story in
this where a local broker,
um, ends up being sentenced to prison.
Do you remember that part of it or not?
Okay. Mark, can you give
us a little recap on mark?
Uh, Mark Kellogg, uh,
submitted fraudulent data for about
70 homes and are somehow ended up,
I'm not sure the process of
flipping a house exactly,
but he did it to about 70 homes and they
all ended up defaulting on the loans
people. So, um,
Mark Shin would be, would it be
what? Let's try somebody else.
What's mark? Well, if mark were a,
a relative of yours and you had to have
Thanksgiving dinner with him while he
was on furlough from
Ohio state penitentiary,
what topic would you
want it to reflect on?
Ethical topic.
I'm gonna take a shot at this.
MMM.
Perhaps just kind of as,
as you can get it though,
as he just kind of mentioned with the
topic of, uh, kind of preying on zebras,
um,
perhaps something like that.
And that kind of using
a position to kind of
benefit from people at a,
at a much kind of like position in you
and kind of did their detriment into your
game.
Okay. So the buyers on your
telling are zebras. Uh,
okay. Uh, I, that's, that's
a plausible possession.
If the buyers are zebras,
are the zebras in any way
blame of bubble in this story?
What do you think?
Um,
it's possible that they're blaming bull
if they were given good information.
But in this situation it seems like
they were given completely wrongful
information, led to believe
that it was true. Okay.
Like a plausible person believe that.
Okay. Uh, can you,
can we tell a story where the home buyer
where it's plausible that blaming the
buyers?
Yes. Okay. Where are they
should have known that they,
if they don't have the income to pay
the okay on it and they weren't there,
they were going to default.
And so therefore they should
have not bought the home.
Thank you.
And uh,
are there instances where people are
encouraged to lie about their incomes?
So I think there's a big problem with a
lot of these jumbos sub prime mortgages
they call them where people were buying
really big houses or second houses with
subprime mortgages.
And in that case it is their fault because
they were just being greedy. Right.
Okay. Trying to take, yeah.
Trying to either falsify documents or go
for the type of loans that would allow
them to get the second properties without
really having enough to back it up.
Okay. So, uh,
that's the Shin of
Shinar pride or gluttony?
Not really glad, but it's
bricks and mortar. Got me.
Yes.
Um,
well there were also a Ninja loans,
which I think is a very appropriate
acronym because of the sneakiness,
but it was an acronym for no income,
no job and no assets.
Okay. Ninja, no income, no job, no assets.
Why would anyone,
anyone encourage another human
being to shake an Angelo?
It's an obvious yes.
Well,
if you're one of the three steps
that profits off the fee of making,
of like having that long go through,
then you don't even,
it doesn't really matter to you if it or
it doesn't matter to you if it default
as much as it matters to
the buyer or to the bank.
Okay.
So long as you can successfully
pass it along to the next step,
you collect the fee and your
home dry no matter what happened.
That's great.
And you're wrapping
up.
Sure. Okay. Now let's stop and see
what we got for a diagram here. Sharon,
unpack, unpack your dining room. Okay,
so I guess I knew you'd be good
at diagram our game of Pictionary.
So I'm trying to out
what exactly went wrong.
And I would start with a home and I'm
the Slavic community and then I would end
maybe here with like
bank of Scotland and um,
between quote unquote Joe six pack,
um,
purchasing a home with
$22,000 yearly income,
which was the average I saw
that was misrepresented as
being worth about 80,000,
um,
from the broker who works with her
that
I figured we could have everyone
fill in the parts for me. Like how,
how do we get from the home to the,
um,
international crisis.
Okay. And so who's, who's the,
we have another mic or not.
Yeah.
Um,
what's the next step in the chain to the,
to the right of broker here?
Oh,
probably someone will give a rating for
this mortgage so that the broker will be
able to package it with other mortgages
and sell it to an investment banker.
Okay.
So there's a credit rating story,
but there's also another story
that's closer to ground level
concerns.
The house itself,
we need a evaluation of the house,
like what the house value of these.
Okay. And there's, thank you.
There's a saying in real estate,
uh,
praise as an instructor
and uh, that and, and it's,
and it's not altogether
false that whoever hires,
think about the incentives.
You're an appraiser and a tall here
hires you to do an appraisal and you're
going to get a fee of 1100 for doing it.
And Paul lets it be known that he thinks
this house really ought to be worth
something north of $200,000
and you go out in the field,
do the copper bowls and
the number comes up at 140.
What
Tim, what thought might
cross your mind if you were,
I understand in your case
of course wouldn't, but uh,
in my case, uh, Mike,
Cross your mind to trust tall and just
go with a $200,000 prediction. Okay.
And the, and the second step
in the reasoning is, um,
no one will ever know no one let her know.
And next time tall goes to the
yellow pages for an appraisal to you,
you'll come to you or he's more
likely to, he said, damn site,
less likely to if you under cut steel.
Uh,
I'll tell you a Yale story
about appraisal. Uh, when
I was in city government,
we leased high street and Wall Street
to Yale for 99 years. We were broke,
we needed money.
And uh,
the mayor sat down with Benno
Schmidt and Petros said,
well, the university will
handle the appraisal for you.
Yeah,
they did.
Uh, the two streets together
leased for $1 million for 99 years.
It should have been a lot more than that.
Uh,
and there were those in city government
who thought I was the guy who got the
number that low. I was actually
pulling hard on making that,
making the number at least one
zero or a year and a half higher.
I had allowed the law school to build
that gorgeous underground library cause
the ground rights went with the street.
Um,
yeah.
So appraise has instructed, this is a, uh,
an important component in the store.
Um,
we got the appraiser there.
So who else was involved and
what are their incentives?
What are,
what's the tall
well, you, you've got the
local bank that's actually
doing the lending. Okay. Um,
and uh,
they probably look at a fee for the
loan that they take and then if they can
package it and sell it
off to someone else. Okay.
They don't end up with
a loan on their books,
so they could probably care less
how it performs over the long run.
Okay. So the terrific. So the lender,
the lender is,
uh,
also feed driven and is,
is inclined to think that she
or he can escape accountability.
Uh, when the property
defaults, it defaults.
And why would that be? What are the what,
what do we turn these loans into it?
The next stage?
That's what I do have to talk to you.
I don't think we know you've talked once.
Go ahead.
Um,
usually it's sold off to a big
investment bank or basically a financial
powerhouse when they pulled off mortgages
into these giant collateralized,
that obligations.
Okay. She d o s famous acronym.
You want to add anything to that?
Okay.
Uh,
so you've got the banks
creating these huge bundles and
the bundles. How, what story could you,
could you tell just say that bundling
these mortgages from all across the
country might be a good thing
from the economist point of view?
Is there anything you could say
vibe to it? Diversifies the risk
for it, diversifies the risk?
Say a little more?
Um,
well presumably the people who are
packaging them can take out a bunch of,
you know, do a lot of, uh,
financial analysis and determined that
the risk of the number of defaults,
um,
would be lower than the benefit of the
people actually paying their loans back.
So the people who take out the,
uh,
the package would have a favorable
risk return. Okay. Uh, and part,
where you about to say something?
Um,
I think it also increases the market of
potential buyers because now rather than
owning a mortgage and having to deal with
an investor one on one, uh, you have, uh,
a pooling and servicing agreement that
has a company as a servicer handles all
the collection of payments
and just reaching up money
into different investments.
Okay.
So you've got,
you've got an institutional mechanism
that makes this work relatively smoothly.
Um,
and
yeah,
you're interested when you create
these bundles in having the risks on
relatively have relatively low
correlation with one another.
You what,
what would be a bad bundle is one where
we can know that some of the mortgages
are you faulting and infer from that,
that lots of others are likely to fall.
And a bundle that was
geographically concentrated
on Slavic village for example,
would have that second characteristic
and that would be a bad thing.
So there is a story about
risk management that
makes that work.
Now are the agencies like Moody's,
these outfits that Judge Credit worthiness
of companies and other and other
financial intermediaries,
are they in this story anywhere?
I don't know if they yawn. Does Moody's
get into your case? I don't know.
I think I found it.
Okay. So, uh,
everybody know what Moody's
and and its rivals. Do
anybody want to help us with that?
Barback here it comes.
I'm slow.
Pray.
Moody's and its rivals are essentially
collect a fee from anyone who wants to
spin off and asset or debt obligation
to actually rate the soundness of the
security for what it's supposed to be
beside a rating like AAA or single. Okay.
And if I'm Yale, is it a trip? What
was triplet? And I think we're now AA.
Um, what's a triple ae? What's
the advantage of a AAA rating?
Uh,
if you have a higher rating,
then that means you can get
a lower cost of capital.
So if you actually want to
raise some money, right,
you can raise it for a lot less.
So reduces the cost of capital and
it therefore has great value to you.
Now, if you could bribe movies, you know,
if you were completely a moral and you
could bribe Moody's to make something a
trip away when it was really being,
uh,
it would be worth paying
a lot, right? The,
the actual economic value
of those ratings is Hume
what keeps Moody's honest?
Okay.
Oh,
the reputation,
the fact that they are years kind of
made sure that the ratings that they're
given actually safe investments.
Okay. Well, and, and in general,
people on the buy side are going to want
the rating agencies to tell the truth
and people on the sell side
will be ambivalent about that.
So they're right there,
there are cross pressures there.
And there is a patent evidence of grade
inflation in the ratings that these
firms produce.
Uh,
does that you
tall?
Not really. No. Because they get paid
by the sell side, not by the buy side.
Absolutely.
So they are doing,
they are in a sense
appraising as instructor.
And that's a pretty scary
part of this whole thing. The,
uh,
let's reach all the way back
to Adam Smith for a minute
and Smith's story, not just of the
invisible hand, but of the general,
generally benign working in markets
in everything Smith says is
embedded at basic norm of truth.
That I'm not selling you a
false mirage of a loaf of bread.
I'm selling you an actual loaf of bread.
I am not selling you a
coffee or assumptions.
Looks like coffee.
I'm Sonia coffee and the
basic accountability in
bilateral trade where you're
buying something from me or
I'm buying something from you.
We keep each other honest,
right?
Where it's two parties and
there's no information asymmetry,
right? Where there are two parties
with symmetrical information.
The most foundational aspect of a market
system is that buyer and seller are
equipped to keep each other honest.
And where there is a huge
information asymmetry,
we invent things like Moody's or
appraisal of real estate as a substitute,
a way of creating or simulating
information symmetry.
But if a third party agencies act like
sellers to the side that pays them,
the information asymmetry
is actually made worse,
right? And the case, the,
the strongest piece for increased
government regulation of,
uh,
the finance industry generally actually
is the difficulty of policing the police
of tracking the integrity of estimates
put out there by people who are in the
business of correcting
information asymmetries.
MMM.
Uh, young. Um,
are there aspects of
the that you would urge
us to pay greater attention to?
Okay.
Well, first of all on the,
uh, on the kind of AAA story,
and this may not be in the case per se,
uh, but it's certainly part of the thing.
Not only is there a nice little boots,
coffee capital if you get rated AAA,
but there are certain funds in certain
buyers like money market funds and other
funds that only dive AAA Bob,
right?
So once you've crossed that threshold,
you were just counting the
number of people, uh, and,
and possible purchasers of your funds.
Because if you put money in
a mark and money market fund,
do you want to reasonably
liquid investment?
You want to reasonably assured return,
uh,
things are not supposed to
be risky investments and
therefore money market funds,
all kinds of other funds
are limited to AAA bonds.
So getting to that AAA level,
what was really important,
uh,
to say something,
even though I'm not a big fan of
their performance in this case,
but in terms of Moody's and Fitch and
everything, the collusion doesn't,
there doesn't have to be
explicit collusion in the
sense that if I give you this
bond to rate,
I will never raise your vibe again
unless you give the a AAA rating.
What happened in this case is the Moody's
and Fitch and others without fairly
explicit guidelines on what they
consider it to be turned away.
So you're the bond package or the IPA
and you're bringing all of the together,
all these mortgages and you say,
I have to reach a kind of 15% threshold
level where it's 15% over collateralize
or I have to buy cds, which are um, uh,
the default swaps in order to ensure this
investment and getting over that AAA.
Huh?
You do exactly what you need
to do to get that AAA rating.
And what happened when the crisis hit
was we had all of these people who are
just over the AAA rating and they,
uh,
I mean with,
with them just over,
you don't have a spread and you don't
have to kind of a usual probability
distribution.
All of these guys who are creating these
CDOs knew exactly the kind of where the
finish line was and when,
just a step over that to make sure that
they were good at the AAA ratings. So,
uh,
the fact that they were not very well
understood that kind of the historic data
went back three years and they felt
very confident in doing stuff with three
years of data.
Uh,
I think that's kind of an interesting way
because when you're looking for active
collusion, the expect that
I didn't see bars, you know,
uh, trading kind of information and, and,
and dollars in Brown paper
envelopes. And sometimes it's, it's,
it's not that explicit.
There are ways that gaming the system
without having anyone do anything that
even resembles something that sketchy.
So
it may be that legitimate cheating,
cheating in a good blue suit is more
dangerous than cheating shady or setting
with sr or,
or, or, you know,
cornea love that's really untested
by a heck of a lot of data.
Also a bad idea. And, and, and I to go on,
I,
I'm actually kind of surprised given that
we're at an elite university with lots
of people with connections to Wall Street
in some way or another that everyone
thought the Zebra was the
people buying the houses.
Uh,
if you look at the data and you have
mark Kellogg's kind of purchase lists
there,
if you look at the data,
you begin to notice not only is there
a pattern in who the appraiser is,
but there are patterns
as to who the buyer is.
We have this one buyer here and I'm
just looking at it in a 40 year period,
bought five houses, six houses,
all with the same broker,
all with the same appraiser.
Uh,
we'd go down and there are
others at seven or eight times,
just look at the names and
they repeat them, the samples.
So I would put the question
back here. Who, who's the, uh,
who's the lion and who's
the Zebra in this case?
Was it the I dance?
I mean,
they were relying on these boats in
Cleveland should do a reasonable job in a
phrasing in, in putting out the, uh,
thing. And in the end, that's what Lynn,
in each of those formulas that I was
talking about, the fact that, okay,
you have houses that are phrased at
this much and historically they fall,
but let's say a 10% rate,
but they didn't take into account the
fact that you have people who are just
figuring the system.
I mean,
going in a six month period of buying a
house at 25,000 and selling it at 85,000
with no evidence of any remodel,
uh,
and it just goes on and you can go through
this data sell sheet is actually kind
of fascinating. If you want to have
a plate, kind of junior detective,
if you want to look to see how
these kinds of patterns in the data,
and you can look at the data adult,
you know, this can't be right,
this really happy,
right,
in terms of who's selling and how
much you're selling to things for.
And especially when you look at the
story of Cleveland and wasn't in a hot
market.
And you can't come up with a story of
like you might for Miami or Las Vegas and
say, well, you know, a lot of old
people are going to move here and,
and that's a good reason.
Land values are going up.
I'm up with a story like that
for Cleveland. Uh, I mean,
it's a wonderful town. Don't get
me wrong, but, uh, there isn't
worse yet.
They've got the Indians and the Brown.
Yes.
Uh,
it's fish and they had the rock and
roll hall of fame, but there's really,
you know,
it's hard to come up with a story.
So why aren't we getting into this
kind of a occurrence and so on.
So, you know, that's a point. I,
so, so one thing that I saw
was I felt like the Zebra
would really represents, um,
potential profits and economic profit
more than an individual in itself.
So if you look from each of
the actors point of views,
the zebra is really what they're,
the profits that they're going after
under the system that's set up. Uh,
so rationally each player is
acting in their own best interests,
but in the end,
in the big picture ends up where
it hurts the system as a whole.
Um,
and so I think that like,
it's very easy to want to put blame on
a specific party or a specific group,
but it's just very difficult to do
because everybody's working under the
incentives that has been
created for that party.
And,
and they offer another potential.
The drugs are considered
when she is, uh, the boats.
Let's say you're buy one of these
houses and is a house next to you,
has been bought for 25,000, sold for
85,000 with no visible improvements.
You bought your home for 30,000.
You put another 40,000 names,
you have a legitimately $70,000 house.
How are you going to deal with in
that house next to you is boarded up,
it goes into foreclosure because someone
has been playing the appraisal. Cancun.
So there is an externality here to
consider to of the overall community.
So who's got an idea
about how to fix all this?
Would it be drumming?
Truth telling him to three year olds.
Okay.
Would it be yes.
I think there's a huge gap
and government oversight, um,
particularly with regard to the
ratings, uh, that, I mean when,
when Moody's is,
although they all,
they have the cross pressures
that you talked about,
but when Moody's is being paid
by one side and not the other,
and even if even if we assume that they're
all inflate it and therefore it was
down to road with them to
be sort of suspect without,
without some third party that's completely
disinterested at like the government
coming in and telling you how to rate it,
you're not going to get,
you're not going to get truthful writings
in there for the whole system falls
apart from the top.
Yup.
That sounds right at mine.
One of my own inclinations would be to
compel the initial lenders to hold a
given percentage equity in each,
each loan,
um,
so that they can't utterly
ignore a probability of default.
Um,
on Monday I'm going to, uh,
Monday is a wildcard in the
syllabus and I had planned to use,
use it to do the Maurice. Um,
the more he's business plan.
Uh,
but it turns out that there are people
who think it would be a terrible idea if
the Morrie's business plan
and got the Yale Daily News.
And while we're 110 really good friends,
I think I'd be nuts to
use that at this stage.
We'll do that at the end of
the semester when it won't be,
when it will not cause bloodshed
somewhere in the system. Um,
and we'll do a, uh, I, I'd like
to do two things with Monday.
One is a poster case on Vioxx the drug,
which
was a Cox two inhibitor and did a lot
of good for people like me with knee
trouble,
but it killed a few of them and there
were hard feelings and a vast avalanche of
lawsuits.
And we'll look at that.
I'm also going to post
federalist paper number 10.
Can I hands up if you've read
federalist 10 k no American,
nobody who's going to do business in this
country should fail to get the idea of
the fundamental design of the
American political system,
which is spelled out in only a few
thousand words there. See, on Monday.